[Music]
so one of the cool things about the
human brain is that we're born into the
world able to learn any of the world's
languages and in fact babies when
they're born they babble using all the
possible phonemes and then gradually
those are pruned away mirroring or their
parents just to be limited to the
phonemes of their native language and in
the same way with music we're literally
born able to enjoy appreciate any of the
incredible rich diversity of musics all
over the world but through exposure we
become conditioned and familiar with
things to the point that it's second
nature and it almost feels absolute to
us in terms of the certainty we feel in
our reactions what's wonderful and so
inspiring and great is also that we can
constantly stretch and expand that and
just as we can learn a second and a
third and even a fourth and fifth
language we can constantly be broadening
our tastes through exposure and growing
what we love and often people are afraid
oh does that mean that I I give up what
I love before no it just like having
more children you just have more love
and you love more music I want to do a
little experiment with you I'm gonna
play you two arias and I want you to
grade them on an emotional scale
we're number one would be the depth of
tragedy and ten is ecstatic joy and so
we'll play you the first clip and then
just take a few seconds to write down
your response to it
[Music]
me
and now we'll play you the second clip
and again do the same thing one is the
depth of tragedy ten is ecstatic joy
[Music]
[Applause]
okay now let's have a look at how you
responded and the answer to what those
areas are is that they're actually both
areas telling about the exact same point
in the story of Orpheus and Eurydice
it's the moment when Orpheus looks back
at you rid achieve when he's leaving the
underworld and by making that mistake he
will never see her again and so it's the
moment of greatest sadness in the piece
but I strongly suspect that you graded
the first one as being quite sad but you
graded the second one as being happier
even though they're representing exactly
the same part of the story and the
reason for that is that the first one is
in the minor mode which we in the West
are conditioned to experience as meaning
sad at a negative effect and the second
one was written before that idea of
minor is sad and major is happy was
actually solidified in Western culture
and so that second Aria is actually in
major even though Orpheus is singing
about exactly the same thing and it's a
great example of how tuned we are to our
culture to respond almost
instantaneously and effortlessly to the
emotional cues that we get in western
music but that's based on exposure and
conditioning it's not something absolute
and so there are cultures in the world
that get married to music and minor the
song Jewish song hava nagila which is
about celebrating life that's in song in
minor again one is just astounded
looking across world cultures at the way
we reinterpret musical expression and
constantly come up with our own angles
and visions which again eventually gets
solidified within a certain cultural
sphere we think about Beethoven as the
most visionary experimental composer of
his day
and yet he never wrote a piece which
used the noise characteristics of the
instruments as expressive features he
never wrote the piece where the pulse
was completely flexible and you didn't
have a steady beat at all he didn't
write a piece where there were all of a
sudden silences interspersed in odd ways
or people could play the same music all
at their own speed and the point is that
half a world away that was the music of
the culture that was actually what was
considered normative that was how people
express themselves in music and so we
all move in these narrow channels but
actually when you take the broad view
music is an open frontier not a closed
system and that's just a model for all
human imagination in general
[Music]